welcome everybody to a new episode of
the h3 podcast starring your boy ty
Lopez y'all remember when he had
attorneys trailing us when we made that
video together well we're gonna do a
little bit of a meme on him we've got a
friend Michael here who is looking very
slick very intimidating as an attorney
and we are gonna have him shadow ty
Gimmelwald taste of his own medicine how
do you think he's gonna enjoy that
yellow we're pranking him got him
let's go welcome everybody to another
episode of the h3 podcast every Tuesday
and Friday at switch W ports legislation
abductions also available on all those
great apps iTunes Google Play tune in go
there
listen download leave a review palpable
us now we've got on deck ty Lopez he's
here the man the myth the legend he's
here in person we also have illa Klein
the illustrious the beautiful the
elegant the Red Hat sent looks like
you're making a political statement with
that hat I don't like that it's just a
red hat Donald Trump love him I hate him
he ruined red hats you can't wear red
hats anymore today's episode is
sponsored by Dollar Shave Club movement
that is MV MT movement the watch company
and quit more on that later
no episode this Friday but stay tuned
because next two days Tuesday coming up
a week from today
it's dunkey video game donkey and his
girlfriend Leah oh my god I love these
guys I'm so genuinely excited for that
one but one guest at a time because I'm
excited for today's guests as well Tai
Lopez yep now before we introduce our
guest today actually want to talk about
something that just happened idubbbz
friends of the show friend of ours made
a new video he made a Content cop on rye
scum mm-hmm a little switcheroo and he
titled it content cop Jake Paul as a
parody too because everybody's begging
him for months to make a Content cop on
Jake Paul and then all of a sudden he
does a little switcheroo cause
content cop Jake Paul and immediately
it's like got you just a joke I just
didn't want to give Bryce calm the
satisfaction of putting his name in the
title and YouTube [ __ ] removed it for
clickbait and deceptive practices and
I'm fired up they gave him a community
strike yeah and they removed it even if
they bring it back they sucked all the
momentum out of the damn video or a lot
of it yeah anyone with half a [ __ ]
brain should be able to look at that and
be like this was purposely done too
artistically to enhance the value of the
video
he immediately addresses it and he has a
reason for doing it and he talks about
it right in the first in the beginning
of the video you know it's fine that
there there's there all the sudden such
strict and forces of the rules meanwhile
you know they're like no porn
unless it's art and then you can have a
dude [ __ ] in another dude's mouth
like they're like this rules okay as
long as it's art but meanwhile when he
actually attempts to make something
interesting with clickbait when everyone
else on YouTube is actually genuinely
click baiting and being promoted in and
paraded around by YouTube all of a
sudden he's got to be the martyr for
clickbait god they always have they
always have this way of not getting it
it's so weird like what what how can
they not understand he immediately talks
about it and he actually has a reason
for titling it that way well while you
have Lance yours raped by a demon yeah
that literally is that not clickbait I I
ask you now so if you want to help I
mean if they don't bring it back that's
gonna be one of the greatest travesties
of YouTube history I think hopefully it
was just some deli I'd buck I don't that
is a bit relevant to what I'm talking
about some some person that and you know
sit in a room with their finger on a
button is like oh [ __ ] this guy in
particular hopefully it gets reversed if
not if you want to help tweet team
youtube tweet them there's real people
there they're connected they see that
tell them yo help a brother out
it's interesting how they
there the guy's been working on this
video for months dude and insanity come
instead of promoting people actually put
effort into a YouTube video they they
just ruining it for him he flew to
England just so that peopIe can make a
brief cameo like this guy went all out
on this video and I think that point is
excellent no one else is trying to like
elevate YouTube videos right and instead
of them appreciating that they find a
way to do the opposite they would donate
don't even reach on be like hey can you
change the title they're just like [ __ ]
you you suck anyway tweet - at team
YouTube if you want to have your voice
heard on that one now with that being
said Tai Lopez is a bit of a legend on
YouTube he's been the subject of a
couple of our videos many of you know we
made a video with him recently where we
went to his house got to know him a
little bit my impression was that he was
a nice guy I liked him I mean besides
the fact that he had like a fleet of
lawyers tailing me but that turned out
for the best I mean was it was a
highlight of the video here my garage
the inventor of this meme the 69 steps
the 420 steps he's a YouTube guru he's a
legend you guys all know him back there
he hates my 69 69 place for 20 steps
so anyway let's bring the man in Tai
Lopez gate that sweet tight little ass I
know you're fit and I know that ass is
tight so bring it in here dammit
69 steps yeah alright thanks for joining
us dude how you been for 420 plays and
stuff so how you been what you been up
to and more importantly what car did you
drive here in the blue Rolls Royce did
you really I
I brought it as a present for you oh my
god Wow I knew you yester that's nice
you can hand me the keys now if you got
him there outside
oh hey so anyway I was in Vegas yeah I
took I took a picture out the window one
hour or two hours before right of that
that festival was insane I left two
hours before really I've been right in
the middle of it crazy world man sad
world sometimes but on that note yeah
you are you you were in Vegas
recently in Vegas I was speaking at a
conference well two entrepreneurs
wanting to scale their business for you
just can you just bring a little bit
close I just want you miss anything
this is don't worry about him did you
bring your lawyer just here to hello
okay don't worry about it snow he's like
an intern an intern yeah he's gonna read
me my Miranda rights
just listen he's uh don't worry just try
not to think about it not here he's the
janitor I'll focus no I'm just kidding
oh my god all right you're starting to
scare me now so thanks for your service
to us appreciate thank you very well
done by the way
lots of intimidation but who's gonna
serve me no subpoena on my podcast on
your part by the way that was great we
thought it'd be fine good I don't wanna
I don't want to like drag it out and
actually have him stand there for too
long no just a little bit of a me you
were getting a little late hearted
that's the new meme the ef'n lawyers at
Ty's house that was powerful that was
definitely the most memorable thing and
it wasn't even really planned I just had
a meeting with my lawyers and they were
there and they're like we got it we got
to meet this guy and I don't know why
bill was hounding you like that they do
not instruct him to do a debrief okay
because that's the number one thing that
everybody was like you have to ask him
about yes he was following me yes I have
no idea why
Oh No so who's it's wool that's a guy
three of but he's a compliance lawyer so
I don't believe he promised you you kid
like a Google lorry
no I believe he's compliance okay but
like what do you think I would actually
be like follow him in the cameras I mean
not that's why it was so crazy right I
think I was just like you guys can
listen in okay
and he took that extremely literally as
relating it listening to every moment so
I and then you know this is Hollywood
you want to you want to entertain you
got to be a little crazy so I didn't say
anything I was like I know your audience
is gonna this is gonna spark brand new
conspiracies around about me and I was
like it's a year now you're saying that
it was by design to be entertaining no
and not it was neither but once I saw it
I was like this is this is pretty funny
I mean it was definite was funny and you
were good with the game you guys are
good with the cameras you like turned it
into a central theme of the whole it was
I mean props to that guy but David were
you like dude why the three yeah the
balcony one is my corner one was funnier
they had like eyes in the wall the photo
you could see their eyes you know if I
really would have pre planted I would
have done something like that I wouldn't
let you know because yeah it was pretty
ham-handed yeah the way he did it
yeah well people like the end to I get a
lot of people being like did you really
throw really out and his wife stayed
surprising people like Pro Wrestling Oh
lots of stuff it was a bit of a progress
it was a bit of a pro Russell you can
basically do something outrageous and
50% of people will believe it well that
guy just was I mean there was a point
when I was on the balcony walking down
the stairs yeah and he and I turned
around and that's when I had this
realization doc this is a lawyer
trailing me he's not full-time on staff
I I have the other guys were full-time
is he the premium one is what's he know
just he not that cheap so I like 600
bucks an hour yeah he does compliance
FTC stuff resuming so like we sell stuff
online if
we have stuff that has recurring monthly
fees you got a word it so it's not
tricking people inside so he makes sure
everything's aboveboard
so he was making sure that was compliant
like that I guess such a good man he's
very well but it got but he got views
did I was so memorable
yeah no I'm happy it happened I mean it
wasn't like I didn't feel threatened it
was just like well no he's a jolly guy
yeah he is he was nice he was a good
sport I remember I walked out of the
kitchen want to know at towards the end
I was like hey I need you to sign a
release you said he was ready lawyers
are very serious you probably would do
that I was surprised it was probably by
the way congratulations congratulations
on winning your lawsuit
oh thanks because I know we were talking
about it there yeah thank you so much
yes that's really yeah you need freedom
of speech let people do as long as it's
not crazy crazy listen today was the big
thing you just did you had some other
content and you did like a reaction
video yeah yeah made a video like we
usually do and this one guy just
couldn't take it and he [ __ ] suit us
found an attorney that was as far as I
could tell ya did it pro bono or on it
on my expense agency and they just you
know they couldn't accept that that it
was alright to make that video right and
so they rode that train all the way to
about how luckily we won but it was a
nightmare yeah well I'll [ __ ] with
lawyers man now I was on jury duty like
two or three years ago on a gang a guy
stabbed somebody in the face and I was
on the jury at my basic it was a month
it was a hung jury in and out wasn't
usually your I was in like 28 days my
basic conclusion was don't go to court
if you don't have to I mean the the
prosecuting attorney suck the D I mean
if you're poor too it sucks the world's
so unfair cuz that yeah defense attorney
was I was like this dude should defend
himself that bad she at the end fake
cried the attorney my client and all the
jurors right when we went in the room
we're like was that a fake cried well
like yeah
it was like so bad I was like poor guy
cost us quarter million to defend
ourselves adequately once we got like
good real attorneys yeah it just it was
kind of disillusioning how how rigged
the system is towards money oh dude
that's insane I didn't grow up with
money so I never saw that side of the
coin but basically especially in America
money runs stuff made money is and
that's why I tell people you know I talk
a lot about money but I'm like money's
more important that we're taught it's
not it it's almost a necessary evil in
the modern world it is for sure yeah Oh
two weeks ago or not last Sunday I was
at the Amish you know I live with the
Amish for two and a half years when I
was young so I was back there and then
the next weekend I was it here there for
Vegas it was quite a the Amish still
have that kind of diverse society not
money driven not material a shirt it's
kind of those are the guys with the
beers and the way beards it's not
Mormons not the opposite sometimes
people don't believe I was there I was
like I still speak their language but
man it's good I got to get out of the
city every once in a while yeah so let
me ask you yeah I know a just to follow
up on the items stuff the video is back
oh it's back yeah sorry this year there
was some YouTube drama going on okay and
one of our friends video got taken down
and we were all just like ranting about
it but apparently it's back up like you
do a new soap opera you know if you put
a hundred bucks in Bitcoin in 2010 you'd
have seventy five million dollars yeah
that's a nightmare someone asked me did
I do it I was like no I wish but like I
was reading it's like yeah you know
there's no such thing as a genius who
was like I predict that boy it's like
you got lucky right forget lucky yeah
anyway listen by the way I'm doing a
huge prize invited 50 of the top Bitcoin
crypto guys to my house tomorrow so I'm
doing a little private dinner because
I'm more of a businessman and I want to
learn more about icos and crypto so it's
gonna be see a future and all that stuff
yeah I mean what the internet did
media like disrupt sure Bitcoin and
crypto currencies ether are gonna
disrupt it's still sovereigns than money
currencies it seems that even now after
Bitcoin and all these other crypto
currencies I've gotten like pretty
famous and a lot of notoriety I still
don't know how to use that right it's
still not able to me that's when the
money is there once everybody that I
think it was JP Morgan or one of these
old billionaires said once you're
shoeshine boys giving you advice on
money it's too late
sure and so like Bitcoin what I never
always tell people never be the first
like I'm good friends with Tom from
MySpace he's actually coming along so
you had first social media platform was
Friendster didn't make any money you
know I do became an alcoholic cuz he had
turned down thirty million bucks come on
by and then it's where it was worth zero
then Tom came along him and his buddies
they built myspace they sold it for five
hundred men they were the second but the
third guy Mark Zuckerberg is one of the
you know almost the wealthiest guy in
the world and so with Bitcoin it's the
same wave 2010 was probably the first
wave I always say get in between the
second and third wave because it went
three yeah I see that you know let the
first guy fail become an alcoholic can
possibly end until my guy who start a
Victoria's Secret he sold it for five
million bucks and jumped off the Golden
Gate Bridge because it turned into a
billion-dollar brand not bad right yeah
not nothing worth ending your own life
over no no no I know no amount of money
jump off a bridge all right let me ask
him okay you were the first person that
I can recall that has kind of pioneered
the genre of like the self-help guru
whatever your motivational I don't know
you refer to yourself but you basically
put your videos your ads on YouTube as
video pre-rolls yes I mean what can you
tell me the process that led you to be
like man I think this is untapped like
right you wait for you the second or
third or were you the person there was
some guy there's a few guys before me
out showers in the second way so you got
it so yeah there's these guys six-pack
ABS no actually
how good their business is doing but
six-pack abs will subdued some guy they
were doing like by their workout plan
mm-hmm but I wish I could say I was
smart I would say I got lucky and all
success is like 50% skill 50% luck you
know I mean you need some skill
obviously but 2014 I mean I've been
entrepreneur since I was 19 I've been
doing stuff and but more behind look
traditional business and then in 2014 I
was like I was at this conference and a
guy's like dude YouTube and YouTube was
already around but it wasn't been I was
like I've learned my mentor Alan nation
told me ty never be the first or the
last to try a new idea so I was like is
someone else doing he's like yeah this
guy seems bad so I said okay so I went
to Europe in December 2014 for New
Year's Eve right before this parachuting
everywhere I go man when I leave god
damn it don't [ __ ] when I leave a
country or city you wanted to leave with
me but uh I come and in that case you do
want to be the first you want to be the
first out that's right but I had order
I've always loved books man and so I had
ordered like 500 books so while I was in
France
my assistant Nathan called me and he
goes dude we got a hundred new books
couple hundred new books no place to put
them I said buy some books I was busy
because I was like on vacation I'm like
buy some bookshelves and put them in the
garage so I came back in right after New
Year's and one night was a Sunday night
that was like January 24th I took a
phone it wasn't this one I still keep
the phones my lucky phone and I walk and
I was gonna go out with my friends and I
remember my buddy Alex Mayer who is this
guy made a billion dollar business he
told me sometimes recreation is
overrated so I was like you know what
I'm not gonna go out today I'm at work
so grab my phone and I had done some
YouTube videos in December but they they
didn't do that good they went they good
so I'm gonna try something new so I had
just got that Lamborghini for Halloween
so I went in there and I was like well
here in my garage just got this brand
new Lamborghini and I was pretty much I
shot a few versions of it and then I
posted it and I remember I had a
conference the next you posted it yeah
posting like January wasn't an ad at
first or was it I posted it and then I
boosted it yesterday
this is pretty good I spent like a
thousand bucks to boost it right so wait
you were you're studying the ab guys
were they running ads or they were just
making YouTube there's any role okay so
you were already interested in it yeah
you made a video like hey this is not
bad
let's try pre rolling it even know if it
was good I was just trying everything so
like trot this is next in line
sure and then I did it and man that
thing all of a sudden is like and yeah
and I was like well apparently people
like Lamborghinis and they're surprised
that I talk about books and people and
you know it was the same thing it was
like in February the next month it's
like forums are like [ __ ] this guy is
[ __ ] that's not a real Lambert there
was theories that it was a fake
Lamborghini a KITT car and all this and
I was like I remember one of my friends
told me for the most part all press is
good press and I was like just let that
roll let the conspiracies roll and yeah
did you get more like more hate or more
love do you get love it all just
skepticism I mean clearly people do sign
up otherwise you wouldn't keep running
Bad's so it's where I get so it it's
it's funny the negativity bias of the
brain is negative people are louder when
I go out on the street in looking in the
last two years a lot of people come up
to me on the street not not sounding to
brag but just stating the fact I've only
ever had two people come up negative
three and I thought I was Gary he was
like [ __ ] you Gary I don't got that one
but people that don't like it but my
theory here's I got a theory for the
theories people gotta have an outlet for
whatever frustrates them and nothing
frustrates people more than money right
yeah that's so you talk about hey you
can make money there like that dude is
now the object of all my frustration
area I think people who generally are
like oh [ __ ] this guy or whatever they
think about you wouldn't if they'd be
like oh that's time maybe they want to
come and say hi because they and it also
proves the point like the Seaboard
warrior right it's like them say hate me
but applauding my demise they don't want
to it were your negative interactions
curious almost all my online in person
never but I thought you said you had to
do one of the drunk guy and one I don't
even remember what it was because I'm
sure is over a girl oh that doesn't know
but he didn't say that but I like asked
around my friends and like I think you
dated his ex so are there are definitely
haters but you know what happens there's
a saying that that a friend sent me
Gandhi said he said first they laugh at
you when you first start cuz I'm who you
are then they hate you and then they
love you it's a cycle and now it's not
but nearly as much because at first
people were like dude this guy rented a
car for one day or this guy rented like
your whole zillow theory that people
still think they're like dude you rented
it for one day I'm like the White House
is on Zillow people don't understand
Zillow works every house and let it
chill by the way I looked it up we were
at the time we're like you definitely
rented this for one day I made because
you and I've seen you around and and you
know I've been around long enough like I
checked the pink slips right there
leases yeah car white cars but yeah it's
leases Elise do people a lie smart
people lease cars because you can't
release my car at least my car you can't
tax write-off a buy no appreciate it
alright so so I haven't seen too many of
your ads lately are you still doing them
yeah yeah okay why are you not targeting
my channel Teich it's tough out there
man we need to take a clip or two of
this yeah yeah yeah we need to get that
for your ol money we need another lease
for you what are you lazy see now yeah
oh you got a test okay neither BMWs I
first time I met Elon Musk I was like
why because that's the electric BMW
looking they're coming they look a
little ridiculous well I think the BMW
it's like a big block Yvan doesn't like
it I know I asked him I saw him at the
movies once and I walked up Thrones like
what do you think of the I ain't he goes
it's I any walk he literally said that
he's kind of funny so I wasn't so yeah
there
nobody drive that garbage I'm entire I'm
a-tellin musk enthusiast okay big big
fan not that was not meant for anything
coughing up a hairball man like a leg oh
yeah looks like a it's a weird also they
have superchargers it doesn't I don't
know how long the battery rides but it's
not it doesn't go that long but what is
this show sponsored by Tesla I wish I
get your theory Kanoe conspiracy here is
number 18 you know what happened once he
followed me on Twitter and immediately
unfollowed really I swear to God I got a
notification that Elon Musk followed you
back oh that's amazing
check nothing what gives dude may break
my heart is there anything that could
possibly be misconstrued as h3h3
he had a friend named Henry and he like
was typing while he drove or he was
eight she's supposed to be AG yeah it's
possible I think it must have been I'm
sure I saw it though I see him a lot
last time I saw him we had a 30-minute
conversation he came up to me at the
Game of Thrones premiere who he likes
movie premiers and he goes I know you do
social media he goes should I put
snapchat I should I put Tesla on
snapchat and use it to promote so I
literally talk about feeling stupid I
gave a 20-minute talk on why I thought
he should and at the end I go what do
you think he goes I think you're wrong
but thank you this guy knows more than
me I disagree but thank you we don't
need it we're already big I disagree by
now when was it in your life that you
decided to make it like your goal to to
be rich right you cuz you kind of you
seemed to be like you've accomplished a
lot but it seems to be an emphasis on
the pursuit of like of money was there a
moment when you felt the urge like I
need to
I need to enable myself and have money
in this way was there something specific
problem what is it growing up without my
that much money but I mean my original
thing when I made these videos I wanted
to talk about what I call the good life
which is health wealth love and
happiness but just everybody is fixated
on the money part well you may ask for
more of that nobody you shift their
focus to show the money yeah but I'm
saying I I had videos that weren't like
that then they don't go with Viral sure
yeah first you know did I tell you this
when I'm a college dropout I went for
like one semester to NC State and I was
trying to decide I had started a little
business than a consulting company and I
asked my mentor at the time this guy
named Allen nation he's the guy who
taught me how to read a book a day and
he goes I said Allen I think I need to
stay in college and he goes why he I
said well people respect you if you have
a degree and I never forget it was on
the phone he's from Mississippi an old
guy goes toot I know this is America
make a million dollars then people will
respect you so I think there's some
truth to that so I would say I'm more in
the pursuit of adventure I always have
been that's why I lived at the Amish
that's why I travel that's why I could
make more money I got friends I'm one of
my best friends dude he just focuses on
money I realized I couldn't do all the
adventures I wanted if I was always
stressed financially and that's my main
message to people yeah not everybody's
gonna be a millionaire not everybody
would he won't want to but there was a
Nobel Prize winner his name is uh Gary
Cohn our economy Daniel Kahneman he says
if you're not making 72 grand a year in
the United States he can chart happiness
decreasing so you got a look at the
Domino's of life like what Domino's do
you have to push that make all the other
Domino's fall and money is a big one
because if you're healthy what's another
one cause a divorce not having enough
money so let me ask you yeah what is it
about being rich that people don't
expect because clearly having money can
also complicate your life and
unpredicted ways yes
so you're saying what's the downsides
yeah what's something maybe that people
wouldn't expect to come from it yeah the
downsides really good I think
I mean I'm single so whenever you meet
girls you got to be like sometimes I'm
out with a girl or like dating and I'm
like look this girl like me if I don't
have money and sometimes the answer's no
some girls would still like I mean I've
dated pretty girls before but there's
definitely a whole subsection of gold
digger
absolutely and same with dudes there's
dudes who want to hang out and you're
like is this dude a real friend or cuz
inevitably after a day or two it's like
yo I got this business thing you want to
invest in so I think that's a downside
and I also think the downside is you
have to be good at being like when is
enough enough because the rust becomes
an addiction and you can just make try
to make money and exclude all the other
stuff you need is there a number and
you're like I've made enough now are you
have you reached that yeah like now I'd
say I mean I started with a hundred
bucks I figured how to make a hundred
grand a year then I figured how am I
going to grand a month then I figure out
how to make it under grand a week now I
know how to make it under grand a day or
more and so now I'm more about like what
are the things that don't I got this
thing 50/50 rule live 50% of your life
selfishly and 50% for the good of
civilization because here's the deal
I've tried to be like like when I lived
at the Amish or doing charity stuff I've
tried to be a hundred percent live for
other people you lose motivation we need
some selfish motivation to get you out
of it and I've also been like a hundred
percent only focused on myself and you
like lose your humanity so I think yeah
I make enough now I don't even have to
make this much well what do you do now
you got all the money you ever dreamed
of make a hundred thousand dollars a day
so you're living for you feel like
you're living for adventure now yeah
yeah and I start new businesses like I
started this Mentor box not a push or
anything like this but it's a cool
company and I work one hour a month on
it and I got a business partner in San
Francisco he does it so when you add up
all the I'm focused now like how can I
make businesses like I said now
businesses are making a hundred grand a
day how can I do more than that but
without me having to do it all but so
why why do you feel like you need to
make more money because you say you're
trying to you're trying to push beyond
that it's not about making money
look here somebody said this
you want to make a million dollars help
a million people that's a good rule of
thumb you want to make a billion or so
Elon Musk is trying to make more money
trust me I met I know a lot of these
billionaires even though they come off
as oh we want to help world I promise
you they are selfishly driven as well
yeah and but I'm like damn let Elon must
be more and more selfish because the
more selfish he becomes to a point you
can take it too far
the more he makes he's got this new
company who's gonna drill holes and make
get rid of la traffic yeah so you know
I'm somewhat capitalistic but sometimes
capitalism sucks too you know it shut
out a lot of people a lot you know what
I'll tell you that I got a lot of things
out but clearly like like let me ask you
this yeah yeah I saw I saw you mate
recently made a video called are you sad
lonely or depressed yes that actually
seemed to do really well and I thought
the message of that video was pretty
pretty nice oh thanks something of the
message was something like you know if
you if you're feeling depressed or
anxious those are feelings telling you
to change course and try something else
right so one of the comments the top
comments on that video was it's easier
to be happy when you're a millionaire
right so what would you say and actually
in fact we were looking at statistics
recently in it recent episode grande
people who are poor actually their
suicide rate is higher like
significantly higher that surprised me
so what would you say to people who are
both poor and depressed yeah I would say
yeah Joel Salatin told me when I was 19
he said Todd there's no change without a
change of routine so if you can somehow
harness depression anxiety sadness and
use it to go enough is enough today's
the day when I almost always there's
some depression that's just chemical
nothing you need a doctor's health but a
lot of people are depressed because one
way or another they got in a crappy
situation I the the top three regrets
humans have or who they dated or married
or didn't date number two
their education most people realize man
I should know a musical instrument I
should know more honest and the third
thing is the career they choose if you
got a crappy job there's a good book
happiness hypothesis which basically
goes through and says for example if
you're an unhappy relationship
there's no meditation no yoga you can do
you're gonna be unhappy so you got to
get out of the chronic issue
yeah that's chronic yeah you put a tack
in your shoe and you feel the pain you
feel the pain every time you walk you
can't just ignore it you know share what
you want to hear something so what do
you do if you're poor you're out there
you're miserable you're poor seems like
you can't you're at McDonald's or
whatever entry-level job it's hard like
how do you step up in life how do you
improve your own situation when you're
you're depressed you're broke it's like
what do you do you know and then you've
got ty on youtube selling this you know
69 style [ __ ] no I'm gonna say that
right 69 steps or whatever but like what
do you what do you know is is is your is
your program gonna help this person what
can they do because there's a lot of
people out there these days shit's rough
right yeah like seriously is it it's
easy they says to you it's easier to be
happy when you're a millionaire like how
do you respond to that person yes and no
I do think you bring the happiness today
some happiness is genetic I've seen lots
of depressed millionaires and shitty
people that have money man I live in
Beverly Hills now I was born in the
ghetto in Long Beach and you find super
happy people that are not so wealthy but
I would say there's truth to financial
stresses a nasty one in the model well
if you worried about paying the rent and
it's you got to ten days to do it it
dominates every other part so I would
say you know I argue I give you I think
the most important tip is if you can
change your social circle even a little
bit success rubs off like there's an I'm
not a dumb guy but I'm not as smart as
Elon Musk but my brains wouldn't have
helped if I hadn't changed my
environment so I did big things like I'd
left the city and I went to this farm
Joel Salatin who was a successful guy in
a peaceful setting and it made me way
happier in danger setting yeah change
your environment man people are
depressed hang out with a whole bunch of
press people
I agree with that with the change of
setting change of friends sometimes yeah
I think I think it's true yeah I mean I
think your analogy about walking around
with the tack in your shoe right is a
good one like if you're that if shits
that bad for you right just
try something new completely new yes you
know what I say when I die I say
everybody should have I call this your
tombstone goal what would you want on
the grave your grave I know it's a
little more of a thought but just go
with me here because Warren Buffett says
to figure out where you learn the more
you learn
among other edition of that but he says
if you want to know what you should do
at 20 you gotta go what what to get I'm
sorry if you want to know what let's say
you're 20 years old and you want to be
successful by 30 right you have to work
in Reverse if I want to be successful in
30 what would I be doing at age 29
and what I'll be doing 20 and you work
yourself backwards to today and I think
that when you reverse engineer success
one of those things is for every person
I've ever met
there's a good book on this called good
to great by Jim Collins it's a famous
business book and he basically says
successful people are lucky but not how
you think because people think you're
lucky like you inherit money or you
launch an app and it goes viral he said
in his studies of the top success in the
last 50 years it's who they bumped into
so my biggest lucky thing was like jump
bumping into Joel Salatin who's this
like down-to-earth super entrepreneur
yet farmer guy sure and I grew up on I'm
in the inner city and then a mobile home
and all of a sudden this guy opens my
brain to like know there's a whole
nother universe sure yeah
and so yeah I mean if you want to get
lucky get lucky on who you bump into
that makes sense to me too I mean I can
say that about ourselves yeah and the
times we've been successful it's always
been I think that's good you expect it
growing up I had this like group of
friends that I I felt kind of like and
you know neither of us was gonna go
anywhere right was always this like
depressing kind of setting this rose
like an island it is just yeah but I I
really agree with that because I think I
ended up I didn't intend for it but I
end up meeting Ethan and then yeah you
know I moved right completely change
setting and I think
that did a lot it's like wasn't
intentional in my head but thinking
about it so what can you do well I guess
you have to be open to it right
everybody wins
you got to go with the flow you know
Charlie Munger who I like the most so
I've never met but the number one god
like to meet his old 93 year old guy he
says it's a rare life that's bathed in
an opportunity most of us only get a few
chances right when you see the chance
jump on it right because what happens is
and this is one of the things that I
hope my youtube videos do my main goal
with the YouTube video is not necessary
by my program does that that it's to be
like change from 100% skeptics cynic to
a little bit of optimism it's okay to be
cynical because there's a lot of I think
they exclude each other
I mean I don't consider myself a cynic
and I and all that's riced you're
balanced right it's kept being skeptical
is a good quality in my opinion yeah but
you're skeptical but yeah I think you're
confusing skepticism with like pessimism
yeah but I think some people are 100
percent you're not a hundred percent you
came at me yeah we're like let's see if
this I guess I guys really they all sure
yeah you see what I'm saying so you take
action that's somewhat awful I think
yeah I'm five flexible cynicism yes yeah
and the truth is in society you need
some people who are like 70% skeptic but
I'm sure that being a hundred percent
skeptic you miss out on big stuff
just think about Bitcoin what I was
saying yeah 2010 I was too much of a
cynic people were telling about 100
bucks I've been doing all this work for
bucks
well that's 75 million yeah but if you
invest in everything everyone's ever
talking about you'll be broke that is
true but it doesn't change the way I
sometimes I wish I was just that puppy
dog person who just loved everyone
accepted everything just my autumn life
you know my cynicism makes me [ __ ]
miserable yeah it serves a purpose you
have a whole following that needs to
hear your thing I'm just saying the day
balance man I know family is same with
making money
I don't want oh I was saying my
tombstone goal I don't want it to be
this dude had money I want it to be
honestly
this guy was a mad scientist and that's
what I kind of feel like like I said I
go from
I'm and I go there's another and now I
end up in Beverly Hills and I'm on
social media I hope that that doesn't
define the rest of my life like I'm
doing something else crazy maybe I'm on
you I must rocket ship with you my
friend are you happy now that you've
been achieved success as you set out
like now that you have money that you
have success that you look alright yeah
I do feel like I'm happy happy sever was
living at home and she's been downhill
since then but I don't only live her
happiness
say that again I think the happiest ever
was when I lived at the office awhile I
just lived there why that's why I always
farm one year ago and I was just there
last week
so what I do I don't think it's
realistic for me to become Amish because
it's a full-on you can be anything
you're a millionaire you've got time
yeah but what are you I'm not I don't
believe they have they're very religious
I don't on the same religion so I'd be a
hypocritical one so I can't really be on
I think part of being happy there is
also like knowing what they there's
possibility still ahead yeah but let me
tell you this I'm gonna tell you
something cool you're gonna like this
there's a test I'm my number one real
passion is psychology by the way not
money if I and I'm launching this
personality test with dr. David buss
who's the number one evolutionary
psychologist he wrote the books for
Harvard and on it there's a test called
the dark triad test okay there's three
dark attributes humans have narcissism
Machiavellianism and being psychotic
okay i test i test people in LA I've
tested tens of thousands of people
you can't believe how [ __ ] up people
are in cities when I go to the Amish if
I don't even need to give them the test
they would score it's a one two hundred
scale a hundred being you're insane they
get like they will get zero zero that
makes sense because they're in a
community they know each other they all
love each other there was imagine being
there's no possible time yeah yeah that
makes yeah everyone cares about you
everyone yes you can have some of my
[ __ ] corn bread yeah whatever corn
bread
this city is kind of hell on earth you
know yeah cuz we're just millions of us
there's only like half a million jobs
yeah and more crazy people move here
every girl every guy that thought they
were talented and beautiful their lie to
you we're going to
how do you feel you rate on that test
I've taken it I'm moderate on narcissism
I'm like not great and not horrible how
do you how do you approach this test
honestly dude it's such a well done test
they trick you you want to hear
something crazy I've had thousands of
people and this one girl brought her
friend about six months ago so her
friend takes the test we're playing
basketball is like take this test I make
everybody take it says she got the worst
score known to mankind she got a hundred
one hundred ninety-five said to her
joking I was like but what are you would
you strangle a puppy like 20 not know
it's tricky they'll do things like give
our parties better when you get there
that's a very Narcis thats like a
narcissist would anyone yeah that seems
like such people you can't believe
mental problem every wall every problem
objectively parties get better when I'm
there this girl I said do I said you I
was just joking my best was like you've
killed someone haven't you she got she
completely quiet so I I pulled her aside
we talked for one hour in my backyard
and she told me I'm the first person she
ever admitted she killed somebody she
was bullied she's from Chicago and she's
like I hit a girl the pipe behind the
head she's like she's either dead or in
a coma hood and and now yes see you
later I was no cuz don't hang out with
the hundreds on that test time what you
do is you never want to be like I never
want to see you again because they're
kind of psychotic I might be number two
I was like that's awesome I'm more you
want to see something funny on my phone
I have so many texts that I that's had
to do but take this and I change their
name to block so let me know my decide
watching W security block block block I
love that it'll change your security
tonight what time man you got lets
people don't cut enough people off so
anyway those more people don't like 83
74 I'm like tricky [ __ ] is this how you
[ __ ] measure the people in your life
how they real no I don't judge lock they
judge themselves one of the questions is
I feel like you have to be
stupid to fill that testimony yeah
alright it's so that's the whole point
do you ever want the craziest question
that people sometimes answer are
strongly agree
do you enjoy picking on losers people
like yes yes that you're an idiot if you
answer yes bull you're like I'm I don't
want to embarrass myself but there's
stupid bullies out there so basically
you have to be stupid and evil to fail
this test so there's no there's some
false negatives but no false positives
okay I love it
so anyway you got you you failed the
narcissism part Donna film right I'm
right in the middle I'm like between
your 46 and 51 so not where I like then
Machiavellian is like 35 what does that
mean you've roll with the iron fist fear
no it's it's yeah it's more like sneaky
okay
so save one thing like if you ever meet
somebody who says to your face I call
you are you and then goes and talk
behind your back
Machiavellian do you change people in
your phone to block hell yeah by the way
I do agree that that I think generally
people need to block out negative people
from their life it's too hard you try to
be a good person try to be compassionate
patient with people you know are like
toxic but sometimes you just gotta say
bye-bye and sometimes in your family
that I doubt it
yeah everybody has one psychopath in
their family mark my words make him take
the test I have six brothers I had one
whom I taken that I know has the most
mental problems he scored super high on
the second one Machiavellian which is
sneak changed his name to block no no my
brother no he goes oh this is stupid
I'll just take it again and lie and
answer the questions differently and I
was like you just proved the point of
the damn test
oh no fail yeah literally he didn't see
all right listen we're gonna take a
commercial break okay guys please be
patient we will be back preciate you god
bless you with Tai Lopez stay tuned
and now a quick thank you to our
sponsors first of all I'm talking about
and the ante you know that stands for
movement this watch here is a slammin
hot item okay
MVM t watches movement was founded on
the belief that style shouldn't break
the bank the watchmakers gold has
changed the way consumers think about
fashion by offering that high-quality
minimalistic product at a revolutionary
price and these guys have sold over a
million watches ok you could say what
you want about me but when you've sold a
million watches you can't say anything
you let's show them your watch I'm angry
that is such a good deal can you calm
down no I'm freaking out I have been
wearing mine today and I really like it
I'll show you take it off look in the
department store this thing is gonna run
you four or five hundred bucks but you
know who doesn't charge that movement
because they cut the middleman out and
they charge you four to five times less
starting at $95 I'm best driver thing
it's got an adorable screwdriver what
more do you need to say so you can
adjust it like I always need to adjust
it because I gotta go with the smallest
option here he'll is an elegant
beautiful lady and with this watch I
mean look how elegant and tasteful it's
over-the-top I was sold with a
screwdriver so it's basically it's a
hundred dollar screwdriver and also
comes with a watch but honestly it's a
really sturdy wonderful build it looks
great it feels great they started just
95 bucks guys and you get 15% off today
with free shipping free returns by going
to nvm t.com slash h3 that's right
they have two URLs apparently you can
also go to mV MT watches calm slash to
h3 I think the first one is more
intuitive just go there MVM t.com slash
ashley movement you will not regret it
because these guys have sold a million
of them so they know what they're doing
clearly so thank you to them appreciate
you
and thank you - you know him you love
him it's Dollar Shave Club that KF / H 3
listen we all know that Dollar Shave
Club makes the best razors in town
that's not debated by anyone but did you
know that they're also making body wash
shampoo hair gel lip balm they didn't
write it here but they also make baby
wipes I didn't forget mm-hmm that's the
highlight of their lineup for me
personally so I'm saying guys get real
they do it all the best and when you can
finish yourself off with the Dollar
Shave Club baby wipe one wipe Charlie
then you know they've got something
going on
well we Charlie think baby was the guy
who pioneered it it's his wife listen I
hate going to the store and shopping for
gel I use a lot of hair gel
but razor is all this stuff you know
it's so annoying it's expensive the
clerk's they don't know what they're
doing you as like a nightmare go to
Dollar Shave Club they got everything
for a limited time they're offering the
[ __ ] shower shave starter kit you have
to respect that this promo is literally
called [ __ ] shower shave it's 5 bucks
guys you get the executive razor with
three trial sized versions of their most
popular products that includes shave
butter body wash and a one wiped Charlie
butt wipes I'm a huge proponent of butt
wipes I cannot support that enough as a
product I have changed my life for me
it's like a paradigm shift you know that
is a baby wipe for me I'm just telling
you and these guys make the best ones
your finger won't even slip through you
won't finger your [ __ ] or anything
you might like that but do that in a
separate time you will also receive
their executive razor which includes the
cartridge you get replacement blades oh
sorry
scratch that after the first box
replacement cards are sent for only a
few bucks a month but you get it first
blade I mean I will use that for months
months right it's true so guys if you
want the butter the shape the bought
wipes
go to dollarshaveclub.com slash h3
that's dollarshaveclub.com slash h3
thank you for supporting us and thank
you to their about white line of product
and finally we have quip lists and guys
when you're done wiping your ass with
the babes when you're done you got your
hot new watch on you're ready to go get
coitus at the club don't forget to brush
your teeth you're you disgusting monster
people don't brush their teeth I don't
understand bad breath but here's some
that will guarantee you never have bad
breath a grant quit here's something
that you want recent studies suggest
having good oral health and backs your
overall health yet most of us don't even
brush our teeth properly you could start
brushing better today introducing quit
the new company that's refreshing the
way people brush their dang teeth quit
is an electric toothbrush that packs a
premium vibration hmm and timer features
into a ultra slim design that's half the
cost of bulkier brushes it's basically
like Apple designed a toothbrush
it's a weird analogy because apples like
overpriced but it is sleek and this it's
basically all the good parts of Apple
and not all the bad parts of Apple in a
toothbrush you can even subscribe to new
brush you can even subscribe to receive
new brush heads on a dentist recommended
three-month plan it's just five bucks
including the free shipping guys quip is
backed by leading dentist and named one
of Time Magazine's best invention of
2016 and apparently Oprah loves it too
really
Oprah's 2017 new list olace she calls it
the O list I'm psycho it vibrates I
trust Oprah the O face list anyway guys
listen this electric toothbrush that I
swear by I am obsessed with oral hygiene
this thing and vibrates it brushes it
gets in there bite starts at 25 bucks
you can't get a good toothbrush for that
price that vibrates not right now go to
quip calm slash h3 to get your first
refill pack free with a quip electric
toothbrush that's right free go to get
quip GE tqu IP doc
slash age three that's GE tqu IP come
slush H three guys if you're in the
market for a watch for some baby wipes
some razors or an electric toothbrush
please consider supporting our sponsors
it helps us out you use all those three
products in combination you will be
receiving coitus my friend that is my
guarantee of you yeah it's like a it's
like a scientific it's not it doesn't
sound sexy
no it's coitus but you'll get it that's
my personal guarantee that is not backed
by cash but anyway let's get back into
the show with your boy ty who probably
uses all these products he's very
presentable so see you guys there
welcome back to the h3 podcast here with
Tai Lopez Tai let me ask you yes do you
[ __ ] like crazy that's it that's an
interesting question what is the
definition of [ __ ] like crazy what do
you think about your well it could mean
you have one girl that you sleep with a
lot or you could have a lot yeah do you
spread your seed no I read that uh one
out of seven I have before I knew had
sex on average and once or twice how are
you yeah I mean yeah yes I shouldn't
have brought up that twitch quote I saw
another one about green cush what are
you uh green cush do you like crazy you
know what I'm not anti you plays weed
but when I do it I feel like it takes me
a month to come back to normal I feel
the same way I hate smoking yeah it
worked great for some people yeah he's
my dog does Greg Wiz Kalifa these guys
seem to be more creative you know you
got to test everything for yourself it
doesn't work nothing works for everybody
I agree you know what it is I think
these guys have been smoking so long
right that it doesn't affect them
anymore right I bet one Snoop was 17
when he started blazing he was like man
I am feel like such an [ __ ] right now
right 10 years later he's like it's all
good baby
yeah he's hollering smut he must have to
smoke a jungle man yeah I'm sure he does
but yeah it's not for me but hey it's
like cat cats to eat what's his name
Katt Williams like man if you're broke
if your jaw I don't have a job I don't
if you're and you're not smoking weed I
do not know what you're doing those are
the best times to smoke when you
literally have nothing important to do
with the same times that it's good to
play World of Warcraft and [ __ ] like
that I think you should do it also when
you're like old yeah because then you
don't care about your brain you're got
Alzheimer's or your degenerate let's
simulate Alzheimer's yeah be relaxing I
think that's the time to smoke let me
ask you what pisses you off the most in
life oh man it's Eve annoying people
that learn slow I mean I like like dumb
just be honest
because you don't have to be super IQ to
get fit like there's a saying I like
three types of people in the world one
makes things happen
second watches things happen and third
wonders what happened like half the I
don't care if you're not doing stuff but
people don't like people how do you
forget a dumb person because you can't
really blame like a person for being
dumb yeah but I'm saying e IQ is like a
glass or like this bottle it's the
capacity for intelligence so you could
have a high IQ and only fill the bottle
up halfway trust me I know high IQ
people that are morons I have a high IQ
friend PhD he said Thai I need to borrow
a hundred 50 grand because my friend in
South America said if I sent him a
hundred fifty grand to export TVs there
he'll give me three hundred grand back
on Friday this was a Monday I said dude
no you ain't this is when I was a
skeptic I said somebody who promised to
double your money
exporting [ __ ] to South America by
Friday I said so I gave him 10 grand
just to be a friend I was like nine give
me home for you he went and found all
these other people got a hundred two
grand put it come Friday I said where's
the money said all the friend just
called me he said he doesn't
I have it on Friday but he's gonna have
for me on Monday that was ten years ago
but you said that's when you were a
skeptic healthy skepticism but now like
now I'd be the same no my point is he's
a high IQ guy doing stupid stuff
sure so I think that dumb is somewhat
subjective obviously some people like
Elon Musk your buddy is good for
something
for a second he's like one piece
probably 155 IQ that's what Bill Gates
is if you use the stanford-binet test
that it's probably that range what's
your IQ
I never say but it's I've been in Mensa
since I was six so I'm high enough to be
in Mensa which now is lower you know how
you know how what is real our Mensa what
cuz they tell you cuz that's the joke
what's the joke about you know someone
who's Apple because they felt the joke
like the dentist's told on your show
they were telling me how to dentist that
well very funny no no there's more yeah
yeah I guess I gotta watch that episode
I thought it was kind of funny about
jumpin landed it was a Cobra was a joke
about Mensa you know how you know the
old men's a joke listen that's been
circulating around the planet you know
how you you know how to tell if
somebody's a Mensa I yeah cuz they'll
tell you how does that money I mean I
felt like a brag yeah but you asked me
first
alright I ruined the joke sorry no yeah
it may have been totally I don't know
podcast is to know there are men so
jokes that have spread throughout
America they're out there man I got a
monitor three I so I don't know if I'm
an intelligent person I've off your
story I can peel hope it was like you
you're not dumb you're smart I don't
think I would rate well on an IQ test me
and you're not as smart as Elon Musk
well you know yeah I mean you've never
seen my results basically if you have
155 IQ you do crazy crap but I don't
like I say the IQ is like it's like
moving shapes and recognizing patterns
and I think I would do really bad on IQ
verbal IQ you have AI is there verbal IQ
tests the stanford-binet test is verbal
and then spatial is basically spatial so
I would feel that
yeah my IQ on spatial is decent but I
have higher verbal you have high verbal
IQ that's why you can be that's why
you're going on YouTube that's why
you're witty that's why you got this I
don't know how is it I call it the
Zillow I got the Zillow conspiracy vibe
this is more good press for little known
fact that's one of the sponsors or
Zillow tell me you're failing the
spatial awareness test I could play just
okay but my one of my my
step-grandfather my grandma got
remarried at 80 she died when I was 8
cool I like that a lot
you can always find love optimism she
wasn't a cynic was she smoking weed no
she's 99 was she [ __ ] like oh she's
still Wow so that's 20 years gone well
he died she's outlived two men men just
died what's wrong with us women just
outlive us right did you know the number
one predictor of being in your hundreds
is being a woman really yeah fall apart
you know it closely killer so what do
you think about the men's rights
movement have you heard about that yeah
most people think of it well let me
preface that yeah I want to I don't want
to take you on ism yeah it's not anti
feminism the way that I understand mints
right is stuff like because most people
think of it as like the anti feminism
but it's like men die you know younger
there there have their more depressed
the divorce process is completely
against men yeah that's true
the courts are favored against women yep
men are more suicidal right so so like
there seems to be some trends where yeah
you know maybe maybe it's harder for men
in some ways right yeah what do you
think about that I think almost every
injustice in the world at some level I'm
big on evolutionary psychology is rooted
in DNA so men die younger because I just
tested my my testosterone is around
1,100 my cousin out there Mya we did her
blood she came back at 30 I was like we
gotta send us back it's broken and the
labs like nope women so men you know I
have 30 40
times higher DNA testosterone the
nourisher testosterone is what makes you
drive your cat fart your far to cast
your car too fast no but it makes you
get in barroom fights almost all serial
killers are men almost all murders are
men sure so some of its di I think a lot
of things we think it's the same thing
with feminists saying that it's in
unjust that women don't get paid as much
as men which is true but it's still
rooted in evolution women have estrogen
it makes you not care as much about
conquering if women ruled the world
there wouldn't be Wars there just be you
know someone that there'd be you don't
believe that there'd be moody he's not
talking to come on there be war is if
women rode the world less women have
wage wars less there have been some
queens well that's such a that's such a
ridiculous hypothec 'el it's like
Amazonians you seen those man those what
Matt do you have country of Amazon no
man look kim jeong-hoon but there's
something do you think there's something
to it like that courts automatically by
by default think that women deserve the
right custody of children even if
they're like addicts yeah i'm not be i
think the court systems are messed up on
a lot divorce yeah i think it should
just be fair you look at the situation
there's no preconceptions about gender
and you go who would be the better
person you hate feminists no I'm kidding
whatever you're the one advocating the
pro man's rights no I agree that I just
I don't know why clean my record we were
done with him yeah a people's rights
people have been paid under the table oh
man feminism I'm just in favor of people
helping people let me ask you what's the
worst someone's ever screwed you over ah
that's a good question I'd say you know
I've been lucky in business I mean the
worst it's probably a non business stuff
business I feel like I'm so I'm more
focused so I try to weed people out
early dating what's the worst day
eating thing I got kicked out of the
Bellagio I couldn't go to for a while oh
my I dated this girl like once or twice
and she came to visit me in Canada and
she had some like she brought like some
shady friends I remember like oh the
hell and one time I walked in my hotel
room and they were in there taking money
out of my suitcase and I was in such
shock like I was like what you know it
takes you water yeah and they took off
down the hall
they ran I got on her like one date she
had been there like took off with this
dude I ran and bucking like crazy as a
man they went right at the exit I like
basically I didn't quite tackle I didn't
tackle the girl but the guy and then the
police came and thought I started it and
they took me downstairs of blasio I
couldn't go to the Bellagio for quite a
while liked it so much so much yeah but
they didn't believe me because they're
like no we didn't this guy just ran us
down and tackled us so so nothing to go
to that Bellagio you know what it's been
long enough that was like seven years
ago they got your face like [ __ ] the
Bellagio I never go there yeah I was
just staying at staying
everybody tweet at the Bellagio I'm
[ __ ] in LA how dare you [ __ ] ass
times I Lopes and hashtag men's rights
yes so the security guards like mm yeah
it is ugly dude we got this girl I take
them to the basement they took me to a
basement you see I'm serious they have
like a whole like jail holding cell down
there it's a little wrong it was I mean
I would I guess people are rowdy Vegas
yeah you don't [ __ ] around there yeah
you gamble a little bit I told you lose
like I just play for fun man blackjack
is like a money hole it's a black hole
of money we've went there with friends
they do high-rolling yes and it's like
you go up even if you go up it sucks it
out you people that come they go yeah
you sit there all night people come to
put thousands down they're killing it
all the money's gone it's just it's so
fast that they just lose thousands in
like a minute
a guy told I was there you know three
days ago or whatever and I asked the
dealer what's the worst she's seen he
said a guy losses like a hundred and ten
grand in like three minutes it's it and
he's like the guy didn't have a lot of
money and he's like I feel
I was probably kids his kids school the
mortgage that's gotta be hard to see and
you know it's funny when you're up you
tip them right you're on don't feel nice
and then when all your money's gone yeah
I just tipped you a thousand but they're
so annoying like I mean there's more
rules than ever there was a guy at our
table who had a spit thing tobacco and
the guys like that is against the rules
yeah people come up and watch they were
[ __ ] mail cuz I was cursing yeah rules
and not let people smoke right in front
of you
I'm like this is what's wrong with the
world it's like marijuana is illegal but
alcohol I mean in a lot of places but
alcohol is it and alcohol 70% of murders
somebody's drunk Oh alcohol bad
decisions life you know in in Vegas I
don't know if this is true I know I
think it was like 10 years ago I don't
know if has changed in Vegas smoking
weed is oil now it's legal in Nevada
right yeah just below before this
billboard when you come in it's life for
all your cush needs so [ __ ] so that's
different now but it used to be that
marijuana was like a like a felony right
and cocaine was a misdemeanor yeah cuz
they're like come here drink at all
coked out you know how many people are
[ __ ] in prison right now rotting
away
you cannot fab I just as a drug charge
anything man because being poor I made
money the black latin Puerto Rican I
just read the story of Attica from the
night you know in 1960s this whole riot
thing I mean dude they used to lock
people up these guys were put in Attica
ice a little prison isolation chamber
for breaking parole at 17 13 years old
yeah if I have if I have one bone to
pick like what the American with
America's incarceration isn't the word
for murder sent yeah of all Americans
are in prison I read that the Missouri
Missouri Supreme Court froze was a few
years ago froze on death row because
once DNA came out 10 to 20% of people
were instantly Pru
you got a death-row live they didn't do
anything that's it yeah I just I just
started a little I gave some money to a
guy randomly I read a paper article this
is a month ago he just got out of prison
he'd been in there since 1994 for a rape
DNA came out that he is a zero chance he
came out and they gave him $100 that is
[ __ ] $100 is what he got from the state
it's hard to be outraged it's so unjust
what it's oh and it's always because
that's what I'm saying when you don't
have money if you can't get a good
lawyer by the way you got a good chance
you're gonna go to prison it's right
women can just be like dude rape me and
course just like okay let's lock them up
yeah it's crazy clearly that's a
sensitive statement right because a lot
of times it's true right yeah but it's
way but the the issue with justice is if
there's any doubt you don't welcome us
because it's better to lock up let free
hundred your guilty people than one
innocent person right that's the guiding
but that's not just now no it's drugs
people went in there for drug I mean it
you should have go to prison for smoking
weed it's [ __ ] sick even even most
drugs is a sickness man people my
brother right one of my brothers got
addicted to heroin at age 14 and now he
works for me yeah he's clean sober for
like a year yeah we have a different mom
it's my half-brother but man it brought
them down a track it's hard to get back
from and when you you have to ask
yourself there's two types of people in
the world there's just people that are
so [ __ ] up you are never going to fix
them and those people you got to keep
away you know people eating people
cannibal yeah violent criminals yeah
this is the only people should be
locking yes and then the rest of the
people you try to that's why I said
Farms man they should put them get a big
farm up in Montana not much around put
people to work do that I love it get in
touch with nitrous for president no hell
no you for president no nope why you
think you could do better than Donald
Trump I think I had wants delusions of
running for public office really but I
think Trump around it become like it's
like a meme now
like celebrities running for office
right you've got Sir Ronald Reagan right
you have Arnold Schwarzenegger right
you've got you've so many celebrities
now and now we have one that's a
president right it was like a reality
star previously and it's just like
people are tired of it there I think I
don't want to know Oprah would be
insurance well I haven't and I heard she
might be President was like I'm serious
Oprah's think if she said she's not
gonna do it but whenever people say I'm
not gonna do it that's when they do it I
don't know I feel about that I know
about Oprah Oprah would be she said
she's the first youngest billionaire
woman she's haikyuu she's smart but
she's also this is what my babies need
to know about like world politics before
you get in like the bullpen do you think
most of the presidents knew that my you
think George W Bush knew that much about
politics I mean he's the guy he's it was
a good you ever see that interview where
George W Bush was asked who was the
pillar of Afghanistan and he goes the
general and the guy goes Jen what's his
name and he goes general video he must
have the best SEO guys they took D index
that [ __ ] for like five minutes the
general Lai Macau is bushy and look for
the day if you find that his greatest
lowers W Bush the George W in retrospect
the guy had low verbal IQ that is
probably true I liked his dad
yes his dad was popular I liked H Bush I
like Bill Clinton cuz he was he was just
like like Willie yeah I got [ __ ]
he did he did for all you twitch people
please comment oh my god Bill Clinton
bucks Hillary Clinton she is not as
dynamic as bill clearly not no bill is
she lost you know Bill Clinton true
story not a humble brag but kind of cool
I was driving to San Diego and Maya goes
ty pull over
I got a FaceTime you and I'm like what I
pull over and Bill Clinton FaceTime me
and she was with Bill Clinton my cousin
she was in Vegas gambling but then
believe it or not oh that's kind we
taught it books cuz you know I always
talk books with these guys so he told me
his favorite books and Hillary told me
her favorite book and Ilan told me you
won't okay
yes tell me you think about you on more
about you on
don't care about this [ __ ] don't care
about presidents these guys are
presidents are not important you've seen
Bill Clinton looks like a raisin don't
tell me about you supple and young looks
like a raisin all good
don't care about him okay all right I've
never thought of him that way but Rob
looks like one of these dancing reasons
I was at the HBO this is a cool little
story I got a video I haven't posted I'm
gonna send it to you and as a Golden
Globes and he was there and I walked up
to him and I said we met before I said
Elon what is your favorite book and why
and his wife / girlfriend was with them
and she pulled him away she's like we
gotta go we gotta go wait a bit oh sorry
yeah go ahead this is your man yeah
eeehm yeah Ely he only [ __ ] the hottest
woman in the world
Elon Musk yeah he's more one girl guy no
he [ __ ]
yeah but he's like Batman you know how
Batman always had like the side chick oh
yeah man yeah he's Batman yeah he does
all right with the women but I said
don't watch your favorite book when a
guy keeps saying by the way what do you
think he said I I don't know I don't
know tell me he goes Lord of the Rings
really and then his wife what a sweet
little way okay so he goes out with us
and I was walking away I said why and he
walks away and I'm like that's the end I
had my little video camera two minutes
later he comes back and he goes I got to
tell you why
apparently this is a big subject for him
he goes because this moral of the story
is you should try something even if you
might fail
that's cute I thought that was cool well
clearly also because it's a help because
it's very rough you would be more
touched by that you were not touched by
that I feel like your cynicism can be
can be I do like optimized by his
optimism I feel like you can't tell the
moral again now you miss it once you
uses a business world your snooze you
fail you try you have he said you should
do something because apparently you can
boil down the entire Lord of the Rings
to that that's what he did your legend
you're your hero your Lord it's a great
book I'm gonna send you a signed
autograph ima say sorry about the data
follow
alright here's the clip by the way oh
he's on like wait wait it's in a room is
this really it please tell me this is it
turn it up
how did you find we have the best
interns in the world here at this time
we have people you wouldn't believe
mence the scales off the change is is
that's the third Mensa test you have
facial verbal and you can you crank it
yes can i snapchat this for one second
am I allowed to snap yeah you can do
that here hey hey everybody entice are
you going oh hey who still uses snapchat
why are we all glowing hey he's got that
glow filter no filter okay
when I hear this yeah this goes in at
the timeline yeah Ali the new Pakistani
general just been elected he's not
elected this guy took over office he
appears he's gonna bring stability to
the country and I think that's good news
for the 700 even general I can't name
the general know there's a longer one
where he literally they asked him 10 the
general look in a way in a way you got
to respect George because he was he was
very forthcoming with his ignorance I'm
surprised you write your George yeah no
I don't know because at the time I hated
him but in retrospect he seems like a
gentle kind so I got I've appreciated
he's painting he's pretty bad yeah and
find a Clinton there exist first they
laugh at you then they hate you and then
what do they do
the goal is to not be a fan they may be
a mouse president that's when your love
George Bush drunk at a wedding have you
seen this it's hard not to love the guy
honestly let me show you this close hey
he's for the people this is this is
turning the George Bush
only in America
but a couple like that be allowed to
unite this being election here you know
they're wonderful people
very Monday people but give me one
little story about Jamie very very
boring person that guy's so important
that he can't be known he's part of the
Illuminati you know one of the things
from h3h3 is people are convinced I'm in
the Illuminati I did a Twitter poll
sixty percent of people say yes or not
sure well I like that not sure there's
actually people out there going kind of
on the fence on that thing yeah I'm on
the fence
I don't like do you think the Illuminati
uses Twitter polls but you're hiding the
lion's den don't you understand
Dan this mic keeps breaking this mic
doesn't like me so let me ask you is
that like the press right things you're
like he's not in the he says he's in the
law not in the loominatee therefore I
cannot take the Illuminati in front of
me do you believe in and do you believe
in my secret organizations like that I
think that secret organizations used to
be more powerful before cellphones now
with cell phones anything secret
somebody's going to snap it it's hard to
do a conspiracy that's it because if you
have an in in a room all the
ex-presidents whoever like they do it
Bohemian Grove I mean these guys all
respect the no cellphone rule yes
nah but somebody's doing it you know I
went to this music thing the other day
and they put our phones in pouches
mmm-hmm you know what people did I was
in the bathroom they were cutting the
pouches
it was Rihanna's dinner cuz Dave
Chappelle was posting and he doesn't
want anyone to steal with Joe I've heard
that he may and I'm like they're like
give us your phone at the door I'm like
ah no this has all my business on it
she's like well you ain't getting in so
I went to my assistant go give me your
phone I handed there that's my
Machiavellian side yes family not one
family that's actually smart we went to
like a Hell's Kitchen showing with
Justin and they yeah they made like Oh
Timberlake yeah
show no justice right why did you see
because I'm trying to think what Justin
wouldn't want a phone there it's usually
not like just in your neighbor it's like
when you come over my house to watch a
game we're locking up phones
what was the Hell's Kitchen thing yeah I
you just met you were in Hell's Kitchen
New York no we were at we were at a
screening of the show Hell's Kitchen I
made us remove our phones it's just so
dumb and then he'll of people were just
I was like oh [ __ ] oh good twenty years
we're gonna laugh about those kids and
I'll be like they used to make you not
snap because like everything's gonna be
live-streamed right
you think so yes well anyway they were
saying and hide your phone and I was
like being all serious about it like
holy [ __ ] and like half the people are
out got the record yeah yeah some people
man those Machiavelli ins new country
I got there's confusion about you yes
you're rich but my question is before
you are rich and you're teaching people
how to be rich because you're rich how
did you get rich it's like a catch-22
I started I've started tons of
businesses you were on a couch it's on a
couch first was first step.you business
was a food business okay well wait I
leased a farm leasing at least a farm
and I got an investor to put in sixty
thousand dollars and we raise cattle and
my first body meets someone who invest
$60,000 in you that's him it was a
farmer
it was another farmer it was a Joel Joel
Salatin he put 60 grand and I made
$12,000 in one year that's my first
profit wasn't much I start I took that
money I traveled around the world to
meet smart people I went to Australia I
went to South America Chile I went to
India I went to Ireland wherever I could
find smart people and then my second
business was a consultant what do you
mean you get off the planer in Ireland I
literally would like email people won't
be like I read your book I would really
like to learn from you interesting and
you it submit you were asking what
should someone do who's like broke or
has a job at McDonald's they hate you'd
be amazed if you email ten people that
you think are out of your league I
promise you one or you know my friend
Frank Luntz I told him this I gave a
talk on this this is like 2012
I said email 10 most important people
want to write you back guess who wrote
them back
I should you not Elon Musk [ __ ] I need
to write he had lunch with you because
part of it was he had this really hot
assistant so he sent a picture I think
he had her send email and then he tagged
along my Corellian pretty slick man that
man melody he's like doom and he came
back like two weeks later he's like dude
want to see my lunch with the alarm
later my lawn must just had lunch with
some pleb yeah but he brought the girl
it was a short lunch I was 20 minutes
with I don't like that story
yeah wait wait you don't like that story
did he ever talk to the girl to anything
happen with the girl now he was normal
well he just came to get a peek at a
cute girl I know cuz she said something
interesting they were talking about okay
you know well it was like a movie he
wanted Hughes he's a movie guy so he's
like I want you to see my script and he
long muscle loves Hollywood stuff by the
way if you wanted me to you tell me
everything about you read close enough I
am at every red carpet event tie I don't
care honestly this one this was a bit I
just knew that you're a Elon Musk
enthusiast I just keep brought you here
to talk about him you know the best
thing he'll on must says you ever heard
of his video on how to argue and think
from first principles mmm-hmm that's
something everybody should do if you're
completely broke or life sucks or
whatever taking on must advice argument
from first principles in a nutshell is
imagine if you had no constraints no
limits what would your plan B and then
so like he just says I want to I think
we need to go to Mars and he just builds
a business before he knows how to do it
I mean god bless him yeah but I'm saying
more of us have to do there
because a lot of people are stumped by
little problems I mean people that are
you know people don't realize one of the
reasons that I have all these online
programs dude you can't believe how many
success stories I get it's insane 67
sets all these programs social media
marketing and the people that do the
best the best this year I launched this
course on how to do a social media
marketing agency this jadyn guy he I met
him he's making 110 thousand dollars a
month at 21 I showed him how to build an
agency and manage businesses social
media it's so obvious no business is no
social media and they'll try
younger people with that so I asked him
like why weren't she skeptical and he's
like oh I didn't know you I didn't he
didn't realize you could be skeptical
that's one cool thing about being young
remember when you're like 18 you meet
somebody a girl or you know you like
dating someone you're like let me love
it's love my life right and you don't
think about the repercussions in this
might you just like go all in and I know
I think you must a cynical part of me
when I hear you say that
okay thinks that you're just heart
you're specifically targeting like
gullible people now I cuz your channel
or use your channel not anymore
I didn't I don't see your beautiful face
great so much anymore my Adsense is in
the toilet
okay well I think I do this now I don't
want back on the show there's a plug
there like let's be nice to tie this is
what I'm gonna say I'm gonna take this
clip in my opening video we'll be like
yo I'm here in my garage I'm targeting a
stream ends right straight out so anyway
back back to where we were because I
found it interesting you're you're
traveling the world looking for smart
people I actually find it interesting
you're like just emailing people in
Ireland yeah and you're like dudes like
cool come see me yeah you got on a plane
you're specifically there to see someone
yep got it I went to this guy Bill
Mollison on there forget he invented
this system called permaculture which is
like how to create and fire mentally
friendly systems where your rainwater
off your roof feeds a pond which grows
fish and then you eat it and so he lived
in Tasmania it's an island so I ran out
of money trying to get to this guy I
took a plane to Melbourne Australia then
I took a plane to I forget what the
capital of Tasmania I remember when I
landed it was completely on fire oh yeah
our city goes on fire our once a year in
the drought I was like what the hell man
through smoke I get there I rented a car
he lived on this before uber on the
other side of island I was driving like
a hundred miles an hour there's like
nobody on the road I come on the corner
there's sheep all whole have no fences
the Sheep just go across the road so I
almost died I show up at his house he's
the weirdest guy
ever and also disappointed but I learned
my lesson from everything you try like
Abraham Lincoln said learn from
everybody even if it's what not to do
and I remember being like never idolize
people too much because even smartest
people sometimes are weird as [ __ ] yeah
sure so I did I stayed for like one day
it was like okay I'm glad I spent all my
money to get here I'll just walk back to
America right yeah so you you travel you
had a farm yep you traveled them what
why didn't have a forum at that time
after the four months yeah after the
farm you travel are you and I came back
to North Carolina my mom was getting
divorced and so I was like I'm gonna go
back help family and that's when I came
back and I had all these farm skills and
this is back in the city and I'm like
these are not marketable skills right I
live with the Amish I know harness
horses I still do I'm not a milk cows I
know how to grow food so that's when I
ended up in a mobile home I grew up in a
mobile home when it from like age 13 to
18 then I came back when my mom was
divorced and there's no room for me so I
got a couch my mom's like and they know
we're here
I'm renting this out and make money just
gave me a couch and that's when I
decided go back to college
I was in college I got a part-time job
cuz like man college is expensive like
people think I can't well can ecology go
to I went to NC State okay and it was I
remember was like $1,000 per either
class or per semester or whatever and I
remember being like that was a lot of
money for me yeah and so I got a job and
I forget what it was like a little dumb
college campus like serving coffee job
and I remember my paycheck after two
weeks part-time was like $80.00 after
after um taxes I was like what
so I remember what Joel Salatin my farm
mentor had told me he's like you know
bootstrap your way out of your problems
so I started a little company it was a
it was a company that consulted on where
you should buy farmland because I was
like what do I know
Funland so I put an ad in this farm
magazine called Stockman grass farmer
for I remember was a hundred dollars in
marketing cost together and I remember
being like a hundred gone again one time
like now me and my business partner
between the two of us I've spent six
hundred million dollars on online
advertise
he spent more than me six hundred
million yeah he's even better than me
kidding me you wouldn't do that much
money but I need to back over multiple
careers no not on YouTube this is all
things combined me and him on YouTube I
probably spent I would say twenty-five
to thirty maybe forty five million bucks
really a lot of impression yeah that's
what I mean yeah you gotta we need that
Tai Lopez who cares about results just
give me a chance where were you
so anyway I put that hundred dollars and
one call came in from a guy I had met
randomly Meritor email people this guy I
had stated his farm in New Zealand
Gary Townsend and he called me goes oh I
saw you start a little consulting
company goes I want to buy land in
America and I don't know where to start
he goes I'll pay you to write an article
so I didn't have a computer so I went in
the NC State little land article write a
white paper on where my recommendation
okay so I've been all around America I
drove all around sure so I wrote him a
paper I basically told him to buy it in
like Missouri and I wrote a to pay to be
page thing on the computer owned by NC
State I emailed it to him he wrote back
thank you and he said what's your bank
account number I'll why are you money
and he said I said what are you gonna
send me goes I'll just pay you the
standard rate I pay all consultants so a
couple days later I think it was either
five or ten thousand dollars in fired
for like for like one hour of work and I
remember going I want to be an
entrepreneur yeah yeah because I had
that eighty dollar check I hadn't cashed
yet I was like I don't want to go cash
to somewhere beyond this inferni and and
so then that was the beginning night
then I got in then I started did I buy
that farm he bought some land he didn't
buy much dude really people just buy
that make plan didn't end up following
your recommendation he didn't he bought
a little bit of merit he no he bought
some but I don't think it was much
because of me these smart people like
that they want lots of opinions so no
patron ten people ten grand pay 100
grand and then they pick one of the
choices fair yeah so
what was I saying here you're you or uh
you understood that's yeah that's when
you understand do you wanna be a nut
review got oh yeah so so then after that
I was still that money I had debts and
stuff so that five or ten grand went
relatively quick I paid my college
tuition and I uh I said to my uncle the
only person my family had ever made a
hundred grand was my uncle doing car
sales so he happened to be one of the
people living in the mobile home his
wife had died of Lou Gehrig's disease
nasty disease and I said what should I
do he said either going to car sales or
finance cuz you don't need a college
degree so I got a yellow pages and I
found this random full-page ads I called
the guy said can I come in tomorrow's
and it was Mike staying back and I
walked in and I said for what uh he was
financial services because when
investments insurance all we're looking
for a job
yeah but he didn't know that I just
called and was like can he probably
thought I was gonna buy so sure I got
this suit that I from the Salvation Army
I'll never forget to head like shoulder
pads
it was horrible man and I walked in
there they were hot pillows woman pant
suits your estranged ever seen an office
where he comes in he's weren't Michaels
do you like the office yeah big fan
Michael Scott has the half female suit
on I don't remember that well back when
I was a kid the the padded shoulders
were hot payables I don't know what it
was but it looked absolutely ridiculous
ratio okay that trying you learn it just
looks like your pads so anyway you want
so I walk in and I was like Mike you
don't know me but if you teach me what
you know I know you're obviously
successful you got a full-page ad this
office I'll work for you for free
and I don't forget he had this big
mustache like that arm Selleck and he
was like this and he turned his big
chair slowly and he goes you know I've
been looking for someone like you for 20
years he goes show up in the morning and
I'll give you an office and you start
working and then that was I was walking
out he looked at me he's from the south
is in North Carolina he goes to I one
more thing if you actually listened to
me one day you'll hug my neck
hug my was a weird thing to say it's a
southern saying it's like okay and I
came in the morning in my office was a
closet with filing cabinet with a chair
that I couldn't love it they put a cold
call list down in front of me Wow and he
said if you can't turn this into money I
you can all split it with you this is
legitimately like a plot from like The
Pursuit of Happyness
yeah yeah like the only things missing
is like a Rubik's Cube oh you know the
Porsche one where he walks up to the guy
in the Porsche yeah yeah I love that
movie I'll tell you very few men or
women can handle the bathroom scene
without crying remember when Will
Smith's there with his son yeah boof you
should play that in prison even parkour
criminals crying on that that scene so
but so anyway you get this job and I'm
in the closet you got the cold calls for
all you don't know what to do
70% of billionaires spent years in sales
so I was in sales and I learned that's
what I'd learned that's the trial by
fire cold call calling and he had me
cold call drew life insurance so here's
the pitch here's the pitch you don't
know me I'm interrupting your dinner and
I'm gonna I want you to pay money today
for things that will benefit people when
you die how do you are you interested
yeah how do you even close that okay
here's what I figured out this is where
you have to be art of war sunsoo best
business book or most popular business
book ever you have to know the enemy now
wasn't the enemy but you have to know
who you're facing and I realized don't
sound are the men sell to the wives mmm
free so when I call I'd be like as mrs.
so-and-so and I'd be like if something
happened to your husband and these are
like you can hear the babies crying in
the background they got a mortgage
awesome the wife like hell yeah I want
life insurance call me I don't know all
right and so that's why I said
creativity gets you out of your problems
most people when they reach I read
something and said the 70% of people
quit when they reach one obstacle
anything lifting weights starting a
business but then another 20% so like
90% of people quit after two and 99% of
people quit after three so a lot of
people if you give them that cold call
list they just three obstacles or like I
can't do this
scout yeah I was I don't think I was
smart or admirable I just didn't know I
could quit I had no other options right
I was like well I guess I gotta get
smart I love the I love that angle of
like going into your dream job and be
like I'll work for free yeah because I'm
pretty sure to anyone who's listening
here is trying to improve their
situation that that works yep for
example our intern just to say the guy
god bless in the intern he emailed us
Cole I mailed us and was like hey I'm in
school I am a fan I want to be an intern
and we just like blew him off and blew
him off and blew him off and didn't
answer and he kept emailing us for like
six months and like [ __ ] it listen we
truly it was messaging me and we truly
were busy and we're figuring it out yeah
we didn't know the podcast was like a
new thing we kept making changes we
didn't know what we need so every time
it would message me I'm like try again
later I'm right now try again yeah well
and he kept trying it's been a few
months maybe I've always been
apprehensive about like taking people
through that channel cuz it's always
like you know what it's just a person an
email but he was presentable and he was
persistent yeah and by the way he rocks
yeah so I love that approach of just
like finding that creative end yeah yeah
this guy in the garage the video the
famous garage video a guy found me one
night this is like 2014 and he just
walks up to the door and I to get I get
this still but it's harder to find that
house the house I live in now certain
people put my address all over the
internet well you film there you felt
there people not to be named home do
there it's kind of like one it's not
it's not a joke it's fine but the other
one this dude shows up
and he goes dude I'm basically homeless
I take care of my grandpa he's on his
deathbed and I walked from Long Beach
Wow he walked 35 any I said how do you
find a house he goes I've been walking
for three days I planted that and so he
goes can I have a job and I remember
being like oh my this dude his name was
Christopher Lopez I was like this guy
looks a little sketchy anybody was
persistent he walked home by the way no
I think I got him over home I'm like
dude let me and but he ended up working
for me I said you can come work for me
for a year he worked for me year saved
up money he went and I
in the airport about six months ago in
Vegas and he came up to me he goes ty I
want you to know man I took that money
and now I bought who's from Mexico's
family I bought a apartment complex with
my grandpa well with because it's
cheaper real estate Mexico I ran out
like whatever four eight units and my
rent I make like two thousand bucks a
month on recurring and it's just like
three money yeah
nobody he's like that's it he lives
cheap and then he believe it or not he
goes once a year and does Alaska fishing
and you make a ton of money so he's like
I make a hundred grand there and like 25
grand on autopilot and he's like he's
like twenties like dude I have a lot of
stories like that that's why when people
tell them a scam I'm like dude I wish I
could show you all the people that come
up to me with I mean I'm sure I wouldn't
call it a scam yeah but I'm sure there's
a lot of people who benefit from it and
I'm sure there's a lot of people who
probably spend a bunch of money because
they're desperate for anything and in a
vulnerable place and then just like move
on to something else right
yeah but I guess it's up to the person
you know is that a scam so I know I
don't
I sell online education which is the
saint
I just read an order I don't think it's
a scam I just want to put what is a scam
let me ask you the same is a scam yeah
there's 1.2 trillion dollars in us
college debt colleges are graduating
people that they know there's no art
history job but they'll gladly take your
50 grand and put you in debt no I don't
think it's a scam either but is what's
closer to a scam
50 grand don't charge people 50 grand
and I let me tell you what let me tell
you I was like you're rationalizing no
no I have a hundred percent money-back
guarantee on anything I've ever sold
every penny back there's a Nobel
prize-winning guy what's his name
Joseph I'll remember his name he says he
thinks college is a scam because there's
no refund everything else in America you
can get a refund
and this is what sucks if the college
system had a refund you know what it
would force colleges to do you'd have to
you would test people you coming in oh
you want an art history degree we might
have to give your money back because you
wouldn't you're not gonna be able to
find a job most likely let's do aptitude
test and find out oh maybe you're a
little better
supplied how they just take your money
no I think it's a huge problem what you
trillion what we all grew up expecting
that life was just you go you get a
higher education you get a job right but
now you just leave with a bunch of debt
and no [ __ ] options and nobody's
really telling you that right because
all of our parents went to college they
paid $5,000 they got a degree and they
bought a house by the time they were 35
that was 16 years ago
no I world changes my honestly don't
even necessarily advocate going to
college to to to our fans I think if
you're going for like a hard science
trying to get going 50% shut it yeah
well let me I want to throw this out cuz
I want your honest opinion cuz I have
strong opinions on this I want to see if
I'm off base Coca Cola McDonald's a scam
McDonald's coca-cola they they pray you
were talking about otai are you praying
on the gullible go to the go to the
inner destitute go to the inner cities
there's no not grocery stores or
something right they get they get they
eat they get sustenance they get
diabetes yes that's what they get how
about coca-cola being in schools and
six-year-olds getting cash and hope they
have 50 grams of sugar grams no I think
it's stamp they're getting paid by
corporations public school I think it's
safe so I always tell people the real
scams are so under your nose so obvious
no one thinks they're a scam and then
they think all that little thing the
biggest scams that will mess you up in
life are the ones that society already
accepts me right alcohol is a scam that
it's that it's legal did you see the
thing today that they posted in America
this chocolate egg is illegal yeah but
50 caliber machine gun is it yeah and
I'm I'm not I'm kind of pro guns but I
do think you could have a rational gun
commerce yeah maybe not 50 no machine
guns I don't know I don't understand the
whole debate about it cuz it's like I
feel like whenever you talk about gun
law people who are pro guns get like
it's not like all or nothing right it's
just like they're sent there can be
sensible gun laws yeah I got an ak-47
but I can't have a fully automatic and
then the other and then they always say
like well it's mental health but I don't
see anyone investing in mental health
right so it's like I don't I see nobody
doing anything
about it entrepreneurs will save the
world man for you're an entrepreneur
you're doing something off the grid off
the system
that helps people yes Elon Musk says the
same thing the future of the world will
be saved but capitalism is like yeah you
know like late-stage capitalism it's
like it doesn't really capitalism by its
very nature doesn't really help poor
people you you're depending on like a
few good people who have a good
conscience but like when you have
corporations running the show and making
tons of its yeah I consider that there's
no that's too centralized of talk about
entrepreneurs imagine this if 50% of
people go to college they become
scientists doctors we need those people
but the other 50% go out and start small
to medium size jobs that that employ
people that employ family and that come
up with unique such a lot of problems
gotta be solved locally the central
government can so all these
entrepreneurs are being eaten by Walmart
and Target and [ __ ] bomb Tony's on
Costco not necessarily drop shipping I
train these two guys Jose and Samir
they're 21 and 22 they drop shipping
they're making $200,000 a month they're
probably netting 50 thousand a month so
another success story I mean these are
not made up man and they're competing
with Walmart they're shipping they're
using Alibaba they're getting stuff in
China again stuff manufacture in the US
let me ask you one thing
mm-hmm I want to show you something okay
this guy's name is brats oh good man
died and I do you think that this guy
does Daisy
music yeah he's that he has the gaze of
miracle of miracles it's called I loved
your guys's thing where you caught prank
called what's his name oh yeah Joel
similar to Joel Olsteen
well I don't know so this guy is the
gaze of miracles he's a guru the
self-help guru he's a cure and he walks
out Galilean Utley heroically he flows
is this he weighs Russia or America this
is
International pitbull is not mister
please tell me you're not you don't
think me in this category I just bought
my life Keep Watch because I think maybe
you're judging a book by it's cover
Oh rod so he gazes and it healed so he
doesn't really talk doesn't talk feel
it's beneath him words are beneath them
that's not the real video that made my
day let me give it a real I have a new
strategy how about this I target a tree
a tree channel and I just stare yeah I
think that would kill it my gaze it just
says like I Lopes comment about all of
their gamers that watch a tree a tree
you will now here be the new eSport so
chance what he does and people pay and
he embraces their life so my question is
do you think that you're in the same
category of business as brats away below
him not yet on the level where I gaze in
wonderful years and people think account
but hey learn from everybody so what do
you take from this oh you feel anything
I should pilot my hair grow out busy is
it a sexy look he has I know by that
mean it looks like he's suffer this I
know
yeah the stroke sound guys are like do
we do they mic him the sound guys don't
have to make him no there's no mic
involved he just come here that's cool
he came it started as a money savings
thing he came out to give a speech on
investment investment banking my goal is
to get this guy a TEDx talk I will I
will gaze into your eyes for exactly 18
minutes does he really win let's not
gonna TEDx let's get him straight old
straight to Island get TEDx I did the
[ __ ] today Ted so I think my here's
what I have taken away from this
business tip sure
throughout all podcasts this guy should
be gazing from high down below kind of
like you had the lose that's why the
lawyer was gazing at me it was a case
for sure has he studied under him
yes please
are you gonna make you made a funny
video about me can you make a funny one
about who we have we really he's a class
you've talked to him no we didn't talk
to him did you call my phone and he was
just gazing so there was no I can feel
the gaze interestingly the only face
times that's what I heard are you
serious yeah does he charge money yes
okay this is a scam yeah why
has anybody ever watt have you ever
bought one of my programs you know I
mean I taught at Harvard I taught at
London Business School you know like I
actually know about business and I
actually say I believe that yeah you
know they study my stuff in almost every
business school in America I didn't know
that but yes it's I hope maybe I am
cheeseball but no you're better after I
feel energized my posture I'm tell you
gays that his report excellent they give
him five star reviews here's the thing a
free country you spend your money on him
he makes you feel better then it's a
good use your money psychosomatic people
get psychosomatic placebo this is
definitely a placebo effect I think the
fact that you give refunds is yeah if he
gives a refund I just listen okay we're
gonna wrap it up like different guys
that are funny no yeah I can show you
some more but I'll do that I want to
wrap it up okay fullscreen brazo
fullscreen broads there's a lot of chaos
in this world hmm
people they get out there they're
killing people yes there's there's
there's static warrior divided country
yes is this a question for me or not
just okay you're out of the equation
okay I'm out I'll just back just enjoy
them I noticed I moved his head about
not all Greece it's not always about you
just enjoy the game he went this is
Zoolander dude he's like I'll do a new
gaze you know what he does hard
blink that [ __ ] I've learned one thing
never engage this guy in a blinking
contest a staring contest you will lose
every time his hairline delay everything
I love it
anyway anyway listen
yeah there's a lot of [ __ ] out there and
I want you to embrace the gays embrace
the warmth because all we need now is to
is this is the valuable lesson I drug
listen sometimes it's valuable to just
close your mouth and gaze listen take in
the world don't give out for a moment
okay that's what brazo represents and so
in the spirit of that I think I'm not
and that's not like I don't mean that as
a commentary I'm just wrapping it up in
a nice way okay anyway Thank You ty for
joining us no thank you and I'm amazed
that you found the George W Bush thing
I'm not best in terms of a an intern and
I I do want to say yeah there's one
thing I've learned in life to all you
guys out there
persistence yes in my life has been the
one thing that's always made the
difference
now you got hilla yeah yeah for sure
first time was she not so excited to
meet you well she was wrong I was
American yeah oh really
yeah how I left we met in Israel briefly
we met just for one week I went back
home and I was persistent and I I
thought he's got he's leaving but oh my
god it wouldn't be possible I know I got
some a vacuum left this room my soul
felt sucked out of the room I feel
strangely stronger speaking of the
office I'm in love with a guy told me my
buddy won the world poker tournament
he's really smart guy told me he was you
want to sleep better watch the office
non-stop every night so I've been
watching it I'm like three times through
the whole thing so remember the one game
in the bat when the bat is in the thing
Dwight Dwight true yes so and then Jim
pretends like he was bitten yes suddenly
I feel strong so you were bit by the
gaze abrazo
anyway awesome persistence persistence
h3h3 so you can see my videos pretty
roll oh I love that you like that shot
just keep watching and look for the gaze
of ty anyway I really do appreciate a
lot of fun with all mine are always
awesome people ask me you know you are
very popular guys because very people
have made parody videos of me the only
one that really I ever noticed was yours
oh really when you drop the one I was
like I never heard of you guys I'm like
who the [ __ ] are these pants I got
people coming out of the woodwork I mean
literally people are like I will rent
your house I was like go ahead are my
rent it out I'll sub lease it to you so
Spears he persists and it is a rental
but this office it's a lease there's a
big difference no if there is if there
is a difference by the way I do buy real
estate just I buy land man I just bought
96 acres
bye-bye things that have by long story
lines by land Barry gold
you heard it here oh I didn't say bye
Larry go buy Bitcoin and honey to talk
feminist you heard from Tai Lopez cut
the stream and you don't [ __ ]